before i begin i feel it is necessary to
point out that the news arm of the bbc
has yet to retract apologize or
otherwise address the deeply transphobic
reporting it has engaged in in the last
few months in a pinned comment down
below you'll find my original video on
the topic several videos from the
youtuber sean who has been ongoing in
his pursuit of trying to get the bbc to
own up to what they have done and also a
video from laura kate dale showing the
protests that have taken place outside
of the bbc offices while i don't feel
any of the people behind doctor who are
in any way responsible for this i cannot
in good conscience talk about a bbc
owned property without mentioning this
first until such time as it is properly
redressed thank you
well we've all heard of
ending a season with a bang
you ready for ending a season with a
[Music]
the battle of ranscore ave
colos
i
remembered being
frustrated and
kind of confounded by this
there were a lot of specifics that i
forgot and there were some things that i
remembered
that are worse now that i'm paying more
attention to them
i think in a way while i never really
liked this episode
i think it benefited a bit from my not
having gone back and rewatched it or
thought much about it
since originally seeing it i didn't have
a good opinion of it but it was an
undetailed bad opinion it was uh it just
wasn't that good
going back and re-watching it
uh i've got i've got a lot
i've got a lot to cover here um
terrible payoffs
uh it really it strikes my nerve on
terrible depictions of the very concept
of faith in uh science fiction which is
something i've covered on doctor who
specifically i'm talking about one of
the novels
that the 13th doctor featured in so like
if you really want to hear me go off on
it there you can but i i am gonna bring
it up again here and then there's
a the handful of ideas here
that are
interesting
but don't
matter
at all
so
where do we even start with this well
let's
i suppose start where the episode starts
with the oaks
god chimney why do you suck at alien
names
so much the ux
the
and not only is it a terrible name the
doctor says it a lot the oaks yolks the
oaks the yolks
it's like you wanted to bring extra
attention to how
bad it just sits on the ear and how it
doesn't
it doesn't sound right it doesn't flow
into a conversation every time it gets
set it's like the sentence stops dead so
we can fit in ooks like oh god now
that's nitpicky but
look strap in i'm not gonna have a lot
of nice things to say about this one
so
we start with them
and the whole thing with their species
is they are deeply religious and there's
always only two of them how does that
work from a uh continuing the species
biological standpoint no idea we're
never gonna explore that
does it matter that there's only two no
actually it really doesn't um these like
for all intents and purposes
it makes way less sense that the ux is a
species than if it had simply been a
religious order that would have made way
more sense and would have left no real
lingering questions for me that i've got
about the idea that this is actually a
species and also it's severely reductive
the fact that the doctor's like oh the
yucks are always fanatical and yes the
display of this bax backs that up but
i'm like that's
that's really reductive and i just don't
like it as an approach
to presenting a supposed species
they should have just been a cult which
they kind of are but like making the
cult synonymous with the species don't
love it don't love that but my real
issue
with i'm like
first of all this is a revisit review
you should know there's going to be
spoilers but i'm going to be talking all
over this place and i'm talking about
the ux that's going to include jumping
to the end
and talking about the stuff at the end
so
all right where do we start let's start
with the general notion very common in
science fiction when dealing with people
of faith
that they are idiots
and we'll just assume that somebody who
drops out of the sky you must be our god
do they actually match the specific
description of your supposed or creator
in this case and i actually think that's
a distinction worth making because if it
was just like a more omnipotent thing
then some stuff later like makes even
less sense but just the idea of a
creator like okay fine we'll go with
that but like you just assume that
whoever dropped out of the sky is your
career does he perfectly match
your understanding description of what
the creator is does he know the things
the creator should know
we don't cover any of those questions we
just leave them hanging which means it's
either the biggest freaking coincidence
in the universe that simsha just
happened to land where these two people
were at the time that they were there
and happens to perfectly line up with
something that they will mistake for
their creator
so it's either that
or they are the biggest freaking idiots
in the universe because they just
assumed anybody who showed up
must be their creator
it's one of the two it's either the
biggest coincidence in a series that has
given us more than a few massive
bleeding coincidences that i have
complained about as we've gone this is
either the biggest one by a factor of 10
or they are insanely stupid and
unfortunately given what goes on later
with their betrayal not betray a
portrayal
in terms of what's shown with them and
what gets them on the doctor's side i'm
gonna lean towards the latter because
this seems to again have a very bad
concept
of what faith even is i mean it's very
it's it's insanely frustratingly common
for science fiction depiction this isn't
specific to doctor who this is all over
the place to basically treat anyone of
faith as a fanatic there is almost no
room for someone who simply uses faith
as a guide in their life they have to
believe it at its most literal sense
they're almost always fundamentalist and
they're almost always fanatical so that
they make better straw men if you're
going there which just isn't even really
do this isn't even really doing the
skewing of religion but it still plays
into the same tropes because later on
these people whose faith is so strong it
allows them to reshape the freaking
universe
can have their faith completely shaken
by the doctor showing up and going but
that's not your creator
oh it's not oh
i'm so uncertain now i will now join you
again it just makes them look
really
really
stupid
because this either means
that they have been following a creator
that they've been doubting up to this
point and it's implied that the doctor
bringing up what she brings up it just
is the last straw and what's tipping the
scale in which case why were you doing
what you were doing for a god you
weren't sure was real
so they're either stupid for that or
it's this really belittling sense of
faith that well here let me apply a
little bit of logic to your faith and
that'll
break you out of your beliefs that's not
how faith works that's why you can't
logic somebody out of their religion
they ah
i'm not gonna dwell too much more on
this but it's really it's dumb it's
condescending and the only reason i'm
not going to dwell on it more is i don't
think that skewering religion was
actually the point the way it was in
that novel that i went off on a little
bit ago
but
it is absolutely here same nonsense same
tropes don't like it and again if you
haven't watched that other video that i
referenced earlier i'm not a person of
faith i'm not taking this person i'm not
going you're insulting my religion i'm
not religious i wasn't raised religious
my family's not religious i just think
this is really dumb and belittling and
insulting in a really close-minded way
to look at and continually depict
religion in a genre that i actually
normally like so that's the first big
thing next big thing
simsa
he's back
and boy does that mean nothing like
here's the thing yes
technically he was set up as having
lived at the end of the woman who fell
to earth and on paper because i say this
so much about chibnall's era on paper
you could say that his disappearance and
the fact that he wasn't killed sets him
up to return at some point you can make
that argument
however however a he wasn't that great a
villain in the first dang place he
wasn't super intimidating he was only a
threat just largely because he was
cheating at what he was supposed to be
doing in the first place which he's
doing again here so again he doesn't
come across as a threat he's just
happens to have access to stuff that
makes him a threat which makes him a
buffoon
not because of something the doctor and
the canadians do just by his nature so
that's your first thing he was not a
villain worth bringing back in the first
place but more important than that it
doesn't work even as a follow-up to a
woman who fell to earth because nothing
about where he ended up and who he
hooked up with i.e the ux
that is not
a reasonable consequence
of
his escape at the end of the original
because he wasn't supposed to end up
here the doctor in this very episode
says herself she set his transport
emergency teleport whatever it was
supposed to send him back where he came
from but he ended up three thousand blah
blah blah blah blah years ago on the
planet where these two chuckle heads are
are occupying a gun and mistaken for god
that's not a natural consequence that
doesn't even vaguely make sense so it's
not like this is a fallout of the doctor
or companion or even whatever his face
was who kicked uh simsha off of the
the crane in the first place and she got
all uppity about that this is not a
reasonable consequence of any of their
actions
like honestly
if they wanted to have if they wanted to
bring a villain back and have
consequences for the actions i'm not
saying he fits the actual story here but
crasco would have made a hell of a lot
more sense because i brought up before
ryan
disobeyed the doctor ignored what she
said about what he shouldn't be messing
with and what he shouldn't be doing to
blast kraskow to some point in history
ryan didn't even know where he sent him
that would have made sense to have
consequences to because he was
disregarding the advice given to him by
someone who knows better that would have
been something to have to have these
kinds of consequences to but not simscha
and it's made worse by the fact that the
natural progression to this would have
been something more like what was done
in series one so to make the comparison
series one not in the first episode but
early on introduce us to dalek establish
a dalek show us why a dalek is
incredibly dangerous and then in the
finale give us a fleet of them and so
that we understand oh
oh this is bad here they set it up like
they're going to do that introduce shim
saw at the start
and then
very next episode bring up the stenza
again that's his species put some
emphasis on on their weapons development
that's what that whole planet was in the
ghost monument they're making weapons
what are they using them for this
species is dangerous yes he was a danger
and he was trying to be the leader but
like this species is dangerous so we've
gone here's what one of them is like
imagine what so many of them are like
and now here's that same one again
that's not the trajectory you set up you
set yourself up for something
that you didn't pay off
like why why in that case did you bother
building up the stenza as a species
threat if the only one we were ever
gonna deal with is this one freaking
dude and yes you could possibly make the
argument well maybe the original plan
was to bring the stenza in in the next
series and yes maybe that's possible and
maybe chimnel chickened out on that
after realizing that nobody was
impressed with this guy but if that was
the plan it still makes for a bad season
of television here because again just on
his own he wasn't a villain worth
bringing back and you set up this
trajectory that you undercut
because again him coming back it's not
like he's got all the stenza technology
again that we saw on ghost monument even
well he has some of it i'll come back to
that but it's not like he's suddenly
armed with oh the stenza technology he
was just working with bare bones stuff
and that would have in addition to
bringing him back would have built up
the species as a thing but it's not even
doing that it's just here's that dude
again
now i mentioned like some of the
technology does come back the sniper
bots show up again oh my gosh
okay
the sniper bots were not good in the
ghost monument
but i was prepared to give a little bit
of leeway because i don't think they
actually had a line to cover this but at
least
in terms of the visual presentation you
could make a head canon
that those ones were old hadn't been
used for a while that's why they were so
crap
here
they're just crap
like they get they get beaten
because
graham and ryan get between two squads
of them and then duck and they shoot
each other and yes i know i didn't have
a problem with chimneal doing that later
in eve of the daleks but i was okay with
that for two reasons one
if you got daleks angry enough which you
can daleks can get very angry i could
actually see them making that kind of
mistake a and b because of the nature of
that story and the time loop coming back
into itself that wasn't the way that
they were defeated that was just the way
to temporarily get out of that immediate
situation so
i was okay with that there here this is
just like and now we don't have to worry
about the sniper bots anymore because
they all shot each other oh my god and
then we can start getting into wasted
potential first of all
huh this whole idea
that the planet
has
psychokinetic
waves coming off it that mess with the
mind with the head
you know how that factors into the story
it doesn't
it doesn't what what
why would you set up
a world that by design
and you say flat out messes with
people's heads
if you're not going to have it mess with
anybody's head at any point
the only way the only way in which this
factors in at all at any point in this
thing is that it's an explanation as to
why mark addie who bless him he is
trying so hard he's giving about as good
of performances could have been given
with the material he had but it explains
why his character doesn't know
everything any sort of remembering stuff
as time goes on but you could have done
that just by giving him a concussion
you didn't have to come up with this
idea for a psychic planet when that
notion doesn't fit into anything i'm not
even sure what the themes of this are
but it doesn't fit in thematically and
it doesn't even come in logistically as
to actually being a hazard or a problem
you built up all this thing you give all
the characters like these psychic
dampeners or whatever the hell they are
so that they're not impacted by the
planet later on you have the doctor and
yes take theirs off put them on the ux
and you know what happens you know what
the consequences is of them taking those
off
this
that's it
that's it ah
oh no they got a mild headache what the
heck
how
how
do you come up with a concept that
enables you to really mess with a
character to throw them off the back
foot to give them a hurdle that is
difficult to overcome and just not
have it do
any of that
again
it feels reverse engineered the only way
that i can think that this could have
possibly happened because
i just i cannot i can't i cannot imagine
a scenario in which a writer goes and
the and they'll be landing on a planet
that emits psychic waves
that won't come up and they won't matter
but anyways i i can't imagine that
happening what i can imagine happening
is somebody going okay they're on this
planet and they run into this guy and he
doesn't know what's going on well why
doesn't he know what's going on oh i
should explain that uh well there's like
psychic waves on the planet there we go
well shouldn't that affect to the doctor
and the and the companions oh yeah
you're right uh we'll put psychic
dampeners on them there we go and now
suddenly you have a concept that you
created to cover a logistical issue that
you then had to layer more stuff into to
cover the to cover the potential holes
that come out of that and you've sunk
all this time into something that
doesn't need to exist at all that's the
only way in my mind that i can come up
with anybody
coming up with a concept like this and
doing literally
nothing with it
i should talk about graham because
that's about the one other major-ish
element to this other than the list of
nitpicks i'm gonna finish this whole
thing off with so they do this whole
thing with graham where once you realize
uh simsha is there that he wants to kill
him out of revenge for grace now there's
a couple of problems with this although
it might
also have been a reverse engineered
writing problem because
wanting to do that might be why this is
simsha instead of any other or a group
of stenza maybe it was decided well
graham isn't the kind of person who's
going to hold it against the whole
species he's only going to hold it
against that one guy well i guess we
have to have it be that one guy
except
the problem is
graham is coming off it takes you away
which
while not wholly about
grief and getting over it and loneliness
that was a major element of it
and he had to say goodbye
to a version of grace and
while you can you know make the claim
well it's not that easy if he sees the
you know the guy who killed her again
maybe maybe it will reignite his anger
like yeah
maybe but like narratively that's deeply
unsatisfying
like you just barely
put him as a character in a place where
i'm not saying he's moved on from grace
but where
that notion of i'm now driven by revenge
i'm like you you ju you just had some
degree of closure or at the very least
you had to set aside your emotional
investment in grayson and her loss in
order to do something and now it's
implying that well no well he can't do
that he just did it last episode he just
did that
so that's the first thing the the order
that these episodes happen in that
causes that problem but even in and of
itself
it just seems
a little bit out of character and like
to a degree it almost
kind of works because i can kind of buy
graham
you know thinking
oh this is my chance i'll take revenge
and thinking that that's what he should
do that that's what a grieving husband
should do that's what uh a man who's
been pushed uh to an edge by loss should
do but that he's not actually capable of
doing it except it doesn't put enough
focus on that for that to act like again
on paper that's kind of the arc but it's
not really properly done and then it's
severely undercut by the very end where
he and ryan put zim shaw in to this
stasis thing which i have to assume was
done to theoretically bring him back for
a third frickin time which never
happened i say never we got the
centenary special coming up don't jinx
it
but
they put him in the stasis for
forever in theory and other people have
pointed this out and i'm not gonna
hammer on it as much because i do think
it's the kind of rationalization a lot
of people would do thinking well i
didn't kill them therefore i'm the
better person but it is a little messed
up that you don't kill him but you
trap him for eternity
which some would argue is
worse
now i was going to lay this
alongside some of the other
moral wonkiness with the doctor herself
except it's not made entirely clear if
the doctor fully understands what it is
they did because she's not with them
when they encounter the stasis pods and
like realize what the deal with them is
nor is she there when they lock him up
so it's possible that she doesn't
realize how bad the situation they just
left him in is which
does make her
in curious which is that's odd for the
doctor
but i'm not gonna lay this on the same
level of moral compass
feels off that i felt about things like
uh arachnids in the uk it doesn't quite
have that level that having been said
there
there is a little bit i have some
frustration
with some of the lines that she has when
questioned by ryan and you know she
turns out she has brought bombs and
again
this isn't necessarily a bad thing it
could work as a core component of this
doctor
but again it feels more like
this is reverse engineered because this
is what allows the story as we've
sketched it out to happen so she's
brought bombs with her and ryan points
out you know you said we're not supposed
to be using weapons you got all mad at
me that time i picked up a sniper bot
thing and what she says to him is
also don't cut that back to me
i will change all the time
here's the thing as a general concept
that can work in the same way that for
like 11 the doctor lies that can be a
thing the idea of the rules can and will
change as you better understand them or
as
i need them to or maybe i'm simplifying
the rules down to a way that you will
understand them but they're actually
more complicated and to you what seem
like contradictions actually do make
sense to me
but it's not
doing any of that again it just feels
reverse engineered it just feels like
well uh so she's gonna bring this thing
uh onto the the ship and um because it's
what they want well that sounds dumb
what if they just kill her and take it
well she should have a security plan in
place okay so she'll put a bomb on it
wait wouldn't the companions be like why
do you have bonds oh okay well we'll put
this line in again it's feeling reverse
engineered so these don't feel like
characterization choices they just feel
like trying to plug the plot holes as
you go and then not thinking about what
that means in terms of the character and
whether or not it's bringing up
something that fits what you've been
doing or something you're gonna do
anything with in the future and then
there's like just some random small
stuff the doctor being all like oh
that's impossible with the shrunken
planets like
it's not the pirate planet did it back
in tom baker's era which like i
understand that the audience doesn't
necessarily know that but shouldn't it
be somebody's job on the team to say
something like i haven't seen this since
blah blah blah blah
because this is basically
combining the crush down planets concept
from that with the whole thing at the um
journey's end with the stolen planets
being used to power something it's just
shoving those two ideas together they've
both been done it's not impossible
doctor catch up like i said mark addie
he's trying but he's wasted like any
actor would have been wasted in that
role the ending is technobabble
like there's a few things that aren't
terrible some of it's shot pretty
decently
uh there's a little exchange between
ryan and graham that as much as i may
not think that graham suddenly out for
revenge really works like it's not as
bad as a lot of what else is going there
but it doesn't really work um as as hard
as he is trying to sell it as an actor
there is a little exchange between him
and ryan that i like
and i like the closing speech from the
doctor none of us know for sure what's
out there
that's why we keep looking
i remember watching for the first time
it was about the first time i was like
oh
i think i i'm kind of starting to get
you now and like what your approach
is and how this doctor
ticks um
it didn't help as much as i'd hoped it
would uh going forward unfortunately but
like that's a decent closing moment for
the thing but
wow
this is not a good episode in and of
itself as a finale
as a wrap up as a supposed payoff to
anything
oh it just it just makes everything that
much worse
but what do you think about this one the
battle of rand score avcolos you
rewatched it lately what do you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it patreon's what pays the bills
allows me to do this as my living any
support you can give is a big help but
even if you can't do that there's other
things that there's links to down in the
description other ways you can support
me or other things that i do on other
platforms that you can check out as well
but uh don't worry too much about it the
like share subscribe helped me out as
well but what i really want you to
remember
is you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
hey end credits time which means i need
to shout out some patrons this time i'm
going to be shouting out robin moore
zubin luthfalla turoch oliver b melinda
walters
the oath of boy tt for nabi lax the
poodle zach paul idoln tracy scrappet
vincent paul bartolucci angry casper
toku bl whovian adam rdl taylor shane
ross shaylee gourley and brendan larose
you want to hear me mispronounce your
name check out rewards on the patreon
thanks for all your support
[Music]
um
[Music]